le premier choc était 2001 février 2022
était 2021 pardon une sortie du covid
désordonnée inflationniste il était donc
parfaitement légitime de prolonger le
quoiqu’il en coûte pour ne pas bloquer
la reprise économique en ciblant les
ménages beaucoup de manières de le faire
en Espagne sur les prix de gros c'est
bizarre de toucher au prix de gros pour
changer les prix du détail mais c'est
typique de l'Espagne en France touché au
prix le détail également fait un
Grande-Bretagne mais vous avez vu avec
des faillites de fournisseurs être
direct au ménage sans toucher au prix
formule allemande étalement pluriannuel
des factures formules danoises mais
notre bouclier tarifaire était au cœur
des réponses à ce problème et les
réponses nationales étaient ici
parfaitement légitime et appropriée on
n'avait pas besoin d'une réponse
européenne le nouveau choc à mes yeux et
le choc politique russe à partir de mars
2022 la menace d'une coupure ou d'une
pénurie de gaz le sujet n'est plus le
prix mais les volumes il faut baisser
les volumes consommés et trouver du GNL
ou du gazoduc un peu partout mais il n'y
aurait pas de desserrement net de l’œuf
avant 2025 ou 206 il faut donc serrer la
vis au consommation il n'y a pas
d'échappatoire le bouclier tarifaire
national n'est plus au cœur des remèdes
c'est devenu un couple symptômes qui est
bon une aspirine pendant la fièvre mais
ne ce n'est pas un remède qui agit sur
les causes quand la demande européenne
semble incontrôlée les marchés peuvent
bondir vers le prix de la défaillance
jusqu'à 10000 euros le mégawattheure ce
qui devient un problème européen
collectif et non plus national il y a
donc utilité à une surveillance
européenne des consommations et à des
achats européens groupés